Let's face it, we've all been at one point where an electronic circuit works so well on perfboards
that you want to build more units of it.
But creating these solder traces takes up way too much time.
Or you ogled a new awesome IC that would be perfect for your next project.
But sadly it does only exist as an SMD package, which makes perfboard soldering pretty hard to do.
In both cases creating a proper PCB design and ordering it from a PCB manufacturing house is the way to go to save time and play around easily with SMD components.
So in this video I will be showing you step by step what to look out for when creating the schematic of your project
and how we can then turn it easily into a PCB design that we can order through a couple of simple clicks for quite a low price.
Let's get started!
As a practical example for this video I will be using this relatively simple double-sided PCB that I designed.
Which brings me to the first step of this tutorial.
Planning the function of the circuits.
I knew that I wanted to create a microcontroller based circuit.
That reads the position of a joystick and then sends the values through the RF band to receiver.
Also I wanted to power the circuit through a LiPo battery.
Which means I needed a LiPo charge controller IC, a micro USB port to deliver the power for charging.
And a power switch to connect the battery voltage to a 3.3V regulator.
Which converts the unregulated battery voltage into a suitable voltage for the microcontroller.
Last but not least I wanted to monitor the battery voltage through a voltage divider with the microcontroller.
So that when the battery voltage gets close to 3.4V the RF functionality shuts down and the yellow LED lights up.
And with the function of the circuit planned out it was time for step 2.
Which involves searching for suitable components and creating a paper schematic.
For component sourcing I like to use LCSC.
Because their selection is not only big.
But also because we will be ordering the PCBs through JLCPCB later on.
And we can combine that with the LCSC order and thus save shipping costs.
But anyway once I decided on the main ICs.
Which were the ATMEGA328 as a microcontroller.
An NRF24 as the RF transmitter.
A TP4056 as the charge controller.
And a TPS76933dBVR as the voltage regulator.
It was time to think about the packages.
The package basically describes how the IC will physically look like.
And determines whether it is a THT or SMD component.
For example while the NRF24 is only available as a breakout board in THT.
And the TP4056 is only available as an SMD version.
We do have the choice between THT and SMD for the microcontroller.
But since I wanted the circuit to be as small as possible.
I went with the SMD version.
Which I also set as the standard for the remaining complementary components.
Next I planned out on a piece of paper.
How to connect the main ICs to one another.
And also what passive components are necessary to make them all work.
To find that out.
I had a closer look at all the data sheets of the ICs.
And the recommended example circuits.
And if everything fails you can always google your question.
Which should give you a suitable answer in 99% of the cases.
The last thing to do for the paper circuits was to add breakout points.
So that I could later program the microcontroller.
And also hook up the battery and LEDs to the circuits.
Which will be mounted in a separate enclosure.
Now for the passive component selection.
I mainly went with 0603 as the package size.
Which stands for 0.06 by 0.03 inches.
Or 1.6 by 0.8 millimeters.
There also exists a 0402 and a 0201 package.
But I think 0603 is neither too big or too small.
And can still be soldered with an iron with a bit of practice.
And with the component selection and paper schematic being completed.
It was time for step 3.
Creating a proper schematic.
For that I used the EasyEDA free online circuit creator.
After logging in I created a new project.
And there a new schematic.
Then I simply used their online library.
Which also includes pretty much all LCSC components.
To search for my utilized components.
And firstly imported them into the workspace.
But make sure that you choose components.
With the right package and correct footprint.
Otherwise the PCB design will later not work out.
Once all the main actors of the circuit were imported.
I then used the left aligned resistors with the right package.
And capacitors with the right package.
As the complementary passive components.
And of course we should not forget.
To add male header connectors.
For the breakout points.
Now that we got all of our required components.
In the editor.
We can arrange them to logical blocks.
Which in my case is the power parts.
And the microcontroller parts.
Once that was done.
I utilized the wire function of the software.
To connect all the components to one another.
According to how I planned it out on paper.
Last but not least.
I then added the ground.
VCC.
And battery voltage supply flags to the schematic.
Which not only completes it.
But also ends the third step of this tutorial.
That means it is time for the last step.
Step 4.
Which is PCB design and ordering.
For that.
We firstly have to click the convert to PCB button.
Which automatically throws all the component footprints.
Into the PCB editor.
Shows how to connect them through the blue lines.
And creates a PCB outline for us.
The first thing I did though.
Was removing the outline.
Because as I mentioned earlier.
I needed a specific PCB size.
For the enclosure.
To do that.
I changed the measuring system to millimeters.
Selected the board outline layer.
And used the track tool.
In combination with the given coordinates.
In the down right corner.
To create the correct size for the PCB.
Then I moved the micro USB port.
The main power switch.
And the joystick.
To the required position.
According to the enclosure's cutouts.
To later mount the PCB.
I also added three pads.
Whose size I enlarged.
So that M3 screws would fit through them.
And with that being done.
I placed the rest of the components onto the PCB.
Of course.
You want to separate the power parts.
And microcontroller part a bit.
And also make sure.
That the pins slash components.
That need to get connected.
To one another.
Are physically close to one another.
So that the copper trace length.
Can be as short as possible.
As soon as you think.
Your layout looks logical.
We could use the given auto router.
To do the wiring for us.
But as you might already have guessed.
That is often not the best solution.
So let's do it manually.
By selecting the top layer.
And using the track tool.
To simply connect all the components.
To one another.
But before doing so.
We have to talk about the width.
Of the traces.
Which is usually set to 0.254 millimeters.
If we use an online trace width calculator.
And set the ounce value to 1.
Which is the standard value.
For JLC PCBs.
Then the trace could handle.
Around 0.885 amps.
Of current on outer layers.
Which is enough.
But I always like to work.
With a width of 0.3 millimeters.
Since that gives me.
A maximum of 1 amp.
And with that out of the way.
I created all possible connections.
On the top layer.
While making sure.
To not use 90 degree bends.
Since that is bad practice.
And everyone in the comment section.
Will hate you.
The only problem.
With this top layer wiring.
Was that after a short while.
I was running out of space.
And not all necessary connections.
Were made yet.
But don't worry.
Since we can switch to the bottom layer.
And do the rest wiring there.
Which would be very simple to do.
For THD components.
Since the solder pads.
Penetrate through all layers.
But for SMD components.
We have to create.
A so called via.
It is basically.
A small tunnel.
That connects the top.
And bottom layer.
And just like that.
We can finish the wiring.
Even for SMD components.
On the bottom layer.
Now here is my finished.
PCB design.
To which you would answer.
It is not finished yet.
Since all ground connections.
Are not made.
Well.
For those.
We can simply select.
The top layer.
And use the copper region tool.
To encircle the whole PCB.
And just like that.
The traces got isolated.
And the rest of the top layer space.
Is used as a solid copper ground layer.
Of course.
If you want to.
You could also repeat this process.
For the bottom layer.
At this point.
The PCB design.
Is basically complete.
Which means.
We can click.
Generate Gerber files.
In order to download them.
Or.
We can directly.
Order our finished products.
From JLC PCB.
Which I did.
And after waiting for a week.
I was greeted.
With 10 copies.
Of my board.
Which did not only look promising.
Under the microscope.
But also worked.
Without any problems.
Now.
If you're curious.
How to solder the components.
To such a PCB.
Then definitely.
Make sure.
To watch my soldering tutorial.
About the subjects.
As always.
I hope you enjoyed.
Watching this video.
And learned a thing or two.
About PCB design.
If so.
Don't forget to like.
Share.
And subscribe.
Stay creative.
And I will see you.
Next time.